[Music]
and if you need I probably have if I
don't have it I can get a free 24 hours
feel rapidly if you have a video shoot
you need issues coming out in two weeks
I just have to make a call and I'll get
it for you
I adore Cola million tones many cool put
dj khaled snapshots Akira more success
have enough pillows and somebody just re
thrown here and her killem been house
business in the New Year oh I see you
for a sec Stonewall gamma student on a
speed on the spot Cove Imperium so mom
sub Mara and medium dolla make the enter
from DJ Khaled or Chris Brown area the
speaker Dom so my name is Benjamin
capitalistic people call me Benjamin
cakes but most you guys know me as a
sneaker don school ends at 3 o'clock I
get home outlook for you dinner do some
homework and go straight to the office
space or songs about your gold dome hear
from me MVP
I was man himself you need anything call
ok infidel chameleon I'm the mother of
the sneaker Don to me he's my little boy
but I also see a businessman he had a
goal he self driven he's motivated hard
worker Mona's to remain calm as from
Hank now I'm standing here today the
first person agrees actually got me a
game I was in fifth grade the galaxy
pack came out and I got the LeBron a lot
of sneakers after that probably around
sixth grade when my pens didn't want to
fund my sneaker hobby anymore I just
figure out a way how to get the money
for it and then I realized if I buy five
or ten pairs by paying people to stand
in line for me I could sell it to a
larger clientele and make more money
plus get my shoes for free and then it
just finally broke through any money you
started coming in now first it amazed me
how Snickers can go for like so much
money for like one shoe people charging
a thousand I thought of the controller
something to some donut man be a bizarro
don't count on own on the sneaker dawn
so poor hungry clumsy I'm really excited
to open up a physical store the first
locations I mean to Miami then I'm
sounding LA New York and Chicago all my
friends when they dropped out of me game
they're like it's dead it's over there's
no more like you're not get on this and
you're wasting your time you're going to
lose money not about what was true play
themselves there you don't I cleanse
naked on the you don't like them
[Music]